Một tháng 1 tờ New York Times, được tin, tổng thủ mi đôn nân trăm đang cưng nhắc khẳng năng xà lệnh tiến hành
gơ được không kích mối nhằm bởi ran. Thưa bài báo tổng thống đôn nân trăm
đánh ngày báo cáo về yếu phương án quân sự khăn nhau xong hiện chứ được giả quý định
quý cộng. Cương ngày tổng thủ mi đứa đúng mày tò sửu hộ đối với các quý biểu tình tại
Iran. Hành định Washington sẵn sẵn sẵn hỗ trợ cho một cạnh tổng thăm trăm từ nhiều lần
thị trách chính quyền Tây Rang. Hôm ông Chin ám mổ thông thông trăm cũng nói Iran đang gặp xác dối lớn.
Bởi vì Israel, Hành Tien Rontal's Dutin, Israel đã nân mất cạnh rát chưa khả năng Mỹ có thể
cần sự quân sự với Iran và liên tục trở đổi tình hình về Mỹ. Israel hiện chứ
đừng họ khả năng sẽ chức tiếp hành động nhưng thủ tướng Benjamin Nga Hù đã công khai uống hộ nhóm người
biểu tình. Bởi vì Iran lạnh tụ tối cạnh Iran, ai về tổn là Ali Keminai tuyên bố chính quyền
tổn sẽ không lối bước. Con chỗ tịch của Iran mua mắt bà gơ gà li bác cạnh báo,
Tây Rang sẽ đáp trả nho Mỹ tính hành tình cầu đã biệt Israel và cân tự quân sự của Mỹ trong khu vực là một tiêu hợp phát.
Lánh đảo.